on the mound for the rangers the lefty
from tennessee mike miner he's owen
three with a 689 era rangers come into
tonight's game a half game better than
seattle the rangers at six and nine the
mariners at seven and 11. both teams
looking up to oakland the a's are
leading the division and houston houston
is a half a game better than texas
and he'll take ball four so lewis
is on with two out how about the respect
from the veteran mike miner a 3-1
change-up
to the young kyle lewis that'll bring up
kyle seeger
bouncer towards the mound past the mound
gonna be a tough play elvis bearhands
throws to first in time he just gets
seeger
we'll see if the mariners choose to
review it as the rangers run off the
field
scott didn't hesitate there
yeah no he wants them to take a look at
it both of us hit the oh button there
you go the same time i mean
that's going to be the quickest one yet
yeah call has already been overturned so
that means men at first and second with
two outs
for austin nolan and here it comes
ground ball third base counter falefa
goes to the bag and that will in the
inning marco gonzalez the three start so
far he's thrown the ball really well 15
strikeouts to just two walks but it's a
lot of two seam fastballs that you'll
see from this lefty also the cutter
change of curveball but ground ball
sharply through the left side
base hit for kiner falefa the hawaiian
hustle keeps it going one out single and
the rangers have a man on for todd
frazier
this one out into center field a base
hit kinder philippa
will have to stop at second but frazier
you can make it an eight-game hitting
streak so he sets the table nicely for
gallow
another pitch tenth of the at-bat and
that one comes in and that might have
even gotten a piece of joey
and nick solac who's been hitting
incredibly well of late coming to the
plate
and this one up the middle base hit that
one just sneaks through
two runs will score
solac has given the rangers the early
two-nothing lead
we had to hold your breath for just a
moment and make sure it got through
absolutely this is part of the reason
that nick soloq is getting more and more
time
in this lineup and moving up in the
lineup it's his ability to battle with
two strikes from the shed long junior
evan white and d gordon gets the start
tonight for the mariners in left field
hill about eight
third this inning in the 2-2
swing and a miss and miner gets his
first strike out of the night
[Applause]
2-2
and he strikes out swinging back-to-back
k's for minor
and a little zip on that one at 92. yeah
92 would have played up a little bit
more than that and this fastball just
flat out beat evan white you can see how
he kind of goes down and trying to get
it and it was by him four-seam variety
that we see so often from mike miner
keiner falloff of frazier and gallo
against mariner starting pitcher marco
gonzalez
connor falefa
rips that one down the field line and it
is in for extra bases gordon
almost had it on a dive and was able to
get up and keep connor philippa to a
double but isaiah's two for two just
watched the dive and looks like it
caught his wrist yeah just right there
at the base of the glove and where
his hand meet
they could not come up with it so it is
a lead-up double for isaiah kind of left
all right so two men on for nick solak
he had a similar spot first inning and
he delivered a two-run single it's the
o2 solac hits one on the ground sharply
left side through to left field to base
it connor fluffa hits the bag at third
he comes home and scores
gordon's throw goes into third as
gallows stops at second so the rangers
have gotten to marco gonzalez two runs
in the first a run here in the third
and with one out willie calhoun to the
plate
and willie hits this ball sharply up the
middle that's a base hit
gallo scores easily solac heads to third
four nothing rangers so now the mariners
have runners at first and third with
nobody out and trying to chip away at
that four run deficit here's jp crawford
line drive into right field d will walk
home aaron is on the board here rbi by
jp crawford two outs
one on and here comes center fielder
kyle lewis the one two to kyle lewis
swinging a chopper towards short up of
the ball is andrews the throw to first
low and it's off the glove for the first
baseman todd frazier
lewis is safe at first base
tim lopes will score on the play the
mariners have their second run of the
ball game it's now the rangers 4 and the
mariners 2 the low throw by elvis
andrews a good throw gets lewis that is
going to be an error on elvis andrews
and the mariners will take it
rodriguez
has come into pitch now in the sixth
inning let's see this left-hander on for
game number four through strikeout three
walks into the third inning so far
for rodriguez
2-2 pitch and long strikes out swinging
one away
another strikeout this time evan white
and white's having a tough ball game
that's now 30 strikeouts for him
2-2
swing and a miss
another strikeout for rodriguez with the
slider as he strikes out the side in
order mcgill is on to first face elvis
andrews number eight hitting shortstop
ahead here on two
swinging a miss good start for him
wanted
nice work by mcgill strikes out the
first two men he's finished
the 2-2
caught on and missed boy what a good
inning from mcgill
he strikes out the side in order three
pitchers shy of immaculate history and
the rangers are one out away
from securing the victory
and it is
popped up
near third connor falefa is there and a
tidy 4-2 win for the rangers tonight
they even the series at a game of peace